mexico une agglomération de plus de 20
millions d'habitants
face à l'épidémie de coronavirus dans le
pays
difficile d'imposer un confinement total
plus de la moitié de la population
active survie au jour le jour
impossible pour elle de ne pas aller
travailler si les déplacements sont
possibles les autorités ont en revanche
rendu le port du masque obligatoire dans
les transports publics à l'entrée des
stations
ils sont distribués gratuitement merci
beaucoup
enfilez le s'il vous plaît le métro de
mexico un réseau immense où se croisent
plus de quatre millions et demi de
passagers par jour
une promiscuité qui multiplie les
risques de contamination on a des
paquets de 200-300 masque chacun quand
on en finit 1
on communique immédiatement par
téléphone pour en avoir à nous quand on
voit que le virus s'est répandu de
l'asie à l'europe avant d'arriver ici je
suis vraiment surpris que dans beaucoup
de ces pays on n'est pas encore pris des
mesures comme celle ci
je le mets tous les jours depuis le
moment où je sors de chez moi au travail
pareil retour je fais attention à ne
jamais l'enlever par précaution et pour
la sécurité des autres j'en utilise
chaque jour plusieurs différends quand
j'arrive au travail j'enlève celui sont
je le change est pareil quand je sors
si les masques chirurgicaux sont
distribués dans le métro et certains
préfèrent en acheter de plus performant
dans les pharmacies c'est le cas de
mathilde une musicienne française
installée au mexique depuis trois ans
ici aucune pénurie de masques
le mexique a tout misé sur une
production nationale importante le pays
en fabrique suffisamment pour répondre
aux besoins de sa population et même
pour en exporter à l'étranger une
situation bien loin de celle de la
france et mathilde en est consciente
quand j'appelle mes amis en france ils
ont pas de masque en fait donc je leur
demande s'ils mettent des masques ouais
non pas du tout et c'est vrai que ça les
étonne que nous ici au mexique la
plupart des gens en milieu de semaine le
mexique a dépassé la barre des 1000
décès un bilan important mais bien loin
de celui de son voisin du nord les états
unis